Up to this point a vertex has been defined by just a 3D coordinate, in fact you
can attach a large amount of data to each vertex. Data attached in this way is
called an attribute in WebGL. To visualize a slice through the color cube we'll
attach a different color to each vertex. To start you'll add a triangle to the
scene. To then add a color per vertex use the following kinds of code after
defining the triangle's face. This last lines adds the RGB color attribute by
specifying a color at each vertex of the face. Your task in this exercise is to
make a triangle with three vertices at these locations and with these colors
attached. Instead of these colors in the example code, add a full red color to
the first vertex, a full green to the second, full blue to the third. The GPU
will interpolate the colors across the surface, giving a blend of these colors
in the triangle's interior. To interpolate means to find a value in between two
or more other values. In this case the original data are the three corner
colors, red, green and blue. For example, this point on the polygon is closest
to the green so it gets more of that color, less of the red and less yet still
of the blue. When you're done with this exercise the result should look like
this.